yo boo lay kev podcast
with the homie dave east chad what up
baby what's up man
um i saw you like i want to say
right before the whole [ __ ] got shut
down he was out here in like february
early march like top of the year working
on karma 3
and then everything just shut the [ __ ]
down world shut down i ain't i ain't
like that's the first time i left new
york
yeah you've been like that's what i was
gonna say man like you're usually in l.a
a lot it's been a while um obviously how
has uh
everything that's going on it just
affected your business like like like or
affected your
besides having to stay inside and all
that [ __ ] just was it was there
plans that you know touring or
i know karma three's coming was did
anything get put on hold or delayed
because of what's happening yeah
i did drop survival with november yep
the whole month of december we did the
um the european tour
and then when we came back from that we
were supposed to start the
west coast and like um
south and midwest negative tour we're
supposed to start that in march
it all shut down have you uh i gained
quarantine weight because i was eating
all kinds of i was just bored
bro first like month of the quarantine i
was just at the crib bored as [ __ ]
before in the morning i'd be [ __ ]
microwaving some noodles or some [ __ ]
i know you're like a really healthy guy
was your health ever like affected like
were you eating like
eating worse or no i just i couldn't go
to the gym
so that made it a little different doing
push-ups at the crib and [ __ ] you got to
get back on
pull up some push-ups in the crib the
rough writer's workout planner
[Laughter]
yeah other than that i'm eating the same
i'm eating
still still still eating still smoking
good all that
you're a pretty healthy guy when it
comes to what you put in your body i
remember
i think the last time you came to the
station you were drinking a bunch of
random crazy juice oh yeah you got a
steve i just
watch what you put in your body i feel
like if you want to be here
at what point in time did you start to
like give a [ __ ] about your health and
like started to like
you know do some research about the you
know getting into the juice and [ __ ] and
like
um probably my daughter was born so like
2016.
so i was what like 26. i was i was
drinking lean a lot at that time
right i'm saying i was having on the
lean and um
i don't know i just went through like uh
that was like the first time a drug
affected me
you know i'm sure i never did no other
drug but that [ __ ] had me waking up
sweats all that if i didn't have it i'd
be mad like
that [ __ ] is a drug you know right you'd
be like oh [ __ ] this is this is exactly
like i really couldn't
become that guy like i'm like oh i get
it like
i'm saying you'll be needing it so once
i was able to shake that
i didn't want to do nothing else you
know i'm saying like nothing i've been
on champagne and weed
champagne and weeds you do drink a lot
of champagne i'll do the [ __ ]
everything's like every time i see you
have a bottle i do the [ __ ]
i mean look at it i don't even know what
time it is what is it 3 p.m
you know why because it don't uh i mean
if you drink enough of it you'll be
twisted but it's a you know just keep
you in a good
it's a good vibe how do you all look at
how you bet
yeah i mean for me every time i drink
champagne i just feel bloated as [ __ ]
you bloated then i know i go front
lately i guess cause i drink a lot of
i've been feeling like
heartburn like like something in here
it's that and you're also getting older
yeah that's too yeah
we're getting old bro you know what i'm
saying um karma three i know you've been
working on it you've put out
man a few a few videos um
the karma series is you know i think a
important part of your career and your
legacy
what is the approach to the
this project and and just that series in
general when you know that like
something's gonna go in that karma
series like do you approach it
differently
um yeah i feel like it's more uh
me or like more more of me not really
caring
about like the the standard sort of you
know oh i need this type of record or i
need this
i just beat me just in my own zone um
working with different producers and
just trying to uh
you know get something constantly let
people know i could rap i could i
i would i would y'all fell in love with
me for from the beginning yeah i'm
always show up with that
so i feel like the karma karma series
gives me the opportunity
to um to kind of mix it up you know have
some big records on there but then have
some [ __ ] for the streets
have something for the fans that that's
into that that's into what i do you know
what i mean
i was gonna say did you feel okay
because when you first came out man i
remember being like yo
this dude was like hearing your early
[ __ ] like
i remember finding you on two dope boys
early on and uh
and um that was what you were known for
and then ladies discovered you and now
to change the game plan
and now and now well now you're you know
shout out to all the women that are all
of a sudden listening to some like
some davey [ __ ] that they would have
never have listened to before in their
entire [ __ ] life
but because you're dave easton you're
their man crush monday
um you're bringing them into that world
like what did
do you remember when you noticed like
you be you were becoming like a thing
with the
with the women oh yeah i mean uh after
um
perfect the chris brown [ __ ] i did when
i first linked with chris brown
and that went like public it's
everything it was over it changed stuff
me it changed everything ig [ __ ]
everything
everything it switched up not that it
was bad before but you know
after after you got a record with breezy
it might change up for you would you say
that i think
most of the people who are fans of your
music
right are probably like me or you know
homies right because the kind of [ __ ]
you make
right but would you say your fan base as
a whole
now probably encompasses more women than
anything yeah
i feel like coming in like you said it
was more
uh you were like a breath of fresh air
to hip-hop hip-hop the the
people that loves lyricism like that
crowd 100
then it transitioned into the girls and
then i started doing the acting
so i feel like a lot of my fan base is
um
i feel like a lot of my fan base might
not even know my music or know what
that's what i was going to ask what i'm
saying
yeah i think i feel like some people
just follow you because it's just low
key they're just trying to like you know
what
come on i'm saying if it don't hurt it
don't hurt me at all
no i mean and obviously i'm sure it
hey you'll take any following you can
get man especially in 2020
um talk about like
i just saw was it last month there was
this narrative going around on twitter
that you you're bad at picking beats did
you see that
not only really being on twitter but you
know i think somebody
they typed like they put they posted on
twitter and then they tagged me in it on
instagram
well what's what's interesting about
that first of all i don't agree with
that but second of all
you nas co-signed you and the big hang
up on nas
historically is that he's bad at picking
bees
what do you think do you think i think
people are there for the lyrics same
thing with nas
right but do you think you you have a
good ear for beats or do you think oh
yeah
okay you know what's funny about that
post i know i it was one beat it was
like some wild
and i was on my my instagram live like
just freestyling to the [ __ ] but the
beat was just some loud [ __ ] that
somebody loaded up
and it sounded crazy no i heard it it
sounded crazy like what the [ __ ] is it
took that
and it was like oh his beat selection is
hard like man go listen to my music man
bad beat selection hey i don't think 9's
got bad b selection is what you're into
he let chris webber produce a few beats
that he could he probably could have
kept on chris webber's laptop
[Laughter]
um i know you're a big sports guy um nba
being back is uh
a blessing especially for me who i
gamble a lot so
a gift and a curse actually that was
rough oh yeah like what am i supposed to
gamble on bookie's old i know that would
have been tough times korean baseball
like
bill for real that that was actually
happening korean baseball was the only
thing going on but
how did how they gonna do that like you
gotta you wanna watch it from home
you can't go to the games oh that's how
they're doing what are we talking about
the nba or korean baseball
uh sports in general you say the
basketball's back yeah the bubble
they got the bubble popping oh i'm all
the way out the loop what the hell is
the bubble
really yeah we can go watch them yeah on
tv
oh but you can't be at the game of
course not
that's weird they got the bubble in
orlando so everybody is
in uh a contained space in orlando at
disney world
nba players so they have all yeah every
team 22 teams
the other teams they did they just
didn't make it but
all the games are going to be played
there and they can't leave like
like okay lou williams left for
family reasons and then they found him
at
he was in magic city two nights ago in
atlanta eating hot wings with jack
harlow
so now he's got a quarantine for like 10
days before he can go join the clippers
again
that's crazy the clippers are trying to
win a [ __ ] ring and lou williams is
eating hot wings in magic
city that's crazy but and then like
there was like some you know you know i
mean come on dudes are going to try to
sneak there
we're talking nba players here they're
going to try to sneak the [ __ ] on
into the bubble
some some known instagram thought here
in la
was posting pictures inside of the
bubble she was in the bubble
and instagram instagram by like by point
of elimination found the only nba player
that was following her
and realized that's who she was there to
see and yeah it's crazy
yeah basketball is wild well i was going
to ask you like what are yours i mean
you don't even know what the [ __ ]
going on
i was lost with that one i ain't oh you
know what i kind of heard something
about that my boy um
brick was telling me about that or how
they can't leave yeah it's crazy like a
camp with some [ __ ] that came out
straight up that's crazy
super crazy yeah the bubble is uh yeah
that's it um we were talking off
off camera you were telling me benny the
butcher's on karma three
shout out to benny how's the whole
gazelle the conway
west side gonna [ __ ] with them yeah i
was gonna say like i do feel like
there's
um you know a small
group of artists and you're in that
group that have kind of kept
this rap [ __ ] alive for you know for for
guys like me for people who really
appreciate bars and
that grimy [ __ ] and i feel like griselda
has you know
grizzled a shout out to freddie gibbs
and mad lib and you know there's just
been a lot of dope [ __ ] going on in hip
hop the last few years
but i do feel like it's starting to
become like
all the weirdo internet [ __ ] is starting
to die out
and um and back to the room it's getting
back a little bit man
you know like rosella got nominated for
best group of the year at the bt awards
which is crazy
so they're paying attention to what
people are saying again and i feel like
it's
it's great for you because you've it's
you know you've always done that i mean
like you know i think you've dabbled in
some more radio
type [ __ ] over the last few years
obviously but i never like
but you've never left your sound nah and
i never uh
did was in this [ __ ] for no clout or
nothing like that i feel like that was
the
wave for the last like five years like
this clout oh it's the worst
ever you could do to get something right
like you know i'm saying like i just now
all these guys have fallen
off j cole said it best right about
little pump and those guys
and now these like and and now what
happened like smoked purple
5 000 units don't part about it you can
get in this [ __ ] make enough money to
where even if you know
if you're smart with your money if
you're smart if you get it even if your
[ __ ] is some trash
you get in for that year yeah that's one
year grab those bags
do something with that brand you stay
these [ __ ] was buying lean and
and all kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah i focus
on the music man the
the [ __ ] that got me got me here you
know i mean the music 100
what is um obviously working with benny
on the project who else is on
karma 3. popcorn on there
record with popcorn i got uh mary j
blige on there
oh [ __ ] mary got a joint um
trey songz uh
trying to think who i was rapping um
though i got doughboy on there
boy we just shot the video matter of
fact a couple days ago out here
um trying to think about something you
know the expectations for that marry
record is going to be crazy
since you played method man that's right
this one is one of them
i mean you played math the man in the in
the show on you know what
saying yeah yeah shout outs to the whole
boo yeah
nobody from mutang on the on the project
um no i ain't not this one
not this one it's crazy me and meth got
a new record though
um shout out to um static selective
static is that guy
emf going crazy on that [ __ ] he gotta
put that out though that's the static
record got the record here
yo static man i just want to give some
props to him because he's like our
modern day primo
bro and he's been one thing i could
salute salute this stat
he's from day one always been like the
same way with me like before i deny a
situation
he was always in tune with me and i mean
shout outs to static
100 i just saw you were shooting a video
with j stone
yeah we're doing another one today i'm
locking in um we're putting a little
little
little project a little ep you know
cause you me and nick was gonna do one
you know what i mean guaranteed we was
already talking about that
so i'm gonna do i'm doing with stone
yeah shout out to stone man i think i
think um
you know he was always like slept on for
sure
and stolen a good just a good good [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like i just
just
vibed like we uh we vibe good you know i
mean
and the music when y'all hear the music
that's why i'm just
we've been just trying to knock out how
many records you guys got done
right now i think we might be like three
or four
three or four and we shot the video the
other day uh in this hood
and then we're shooting one today you
you and nipsy were supposed to do a
project i remember we talked about that
before
did you guys have any um music that you
that
that's just sitting on a hard drive
somewhere that y'all never released yeah
how many unreleased songs do you think
you got with it maybe three
this was one with me him and being over
never put out we're beating rideau
this one being on combat 3-2 that was
another shout out to beno beano's fire
that's
yeah that's my boy uh and then
me and him got two two drinks i had one
record that i was gonna put on karma
three but
yeah i was gonna ask you like is it is
it um obviously you're tight with his
team but like
is it like kind of weird putting
something out with you like with him
after he passed you know what i'm saying
i feel like
super weird like the
the um the excitement is going
behind it i'm still excited to do it and
you know let it be known that we did
that and created that but the
phone call you know because you're ready
to drive like all that's gone you know i
mean so it's definitely weird
you i think a lot of people have always
kind of said you're kind of like
what nip is to what nip was to la to
your hood to harlem
right to to like new york somebody who
is like a man of the people somebody
who's never really
damn i got my ringtone on unprofessional
but somebody who uh who you know
when i think of davies i never ever ever
thought of goofy [ __ ] or
i think of integrity i think of you know
when it comes to music and it just comes
to you as a person like
um what was you know obviously you know
you've done a ton of interviews since
nipsey passed um but
we're going on a year and a half since
he died
what is the one thing you think since he
passed
um that you've carried with you and that
you're like like from nip
to this day because you know [ __ ] man i
can't even believe it's been a year and
a half right
like i would say just uh his motto
marathon you know what i'm saying like
the [ __ ] he lived by the [ __ ] he always
said
don't stop you know what i mean like no
matter what what come your way
you gotta keep keep keep rolling you
know i mean and
the fact of ownership and
turning your brand into a business and
just being more than a rapper and i mean
so that's what
really stuck with me the most and just
trying to build my brand
from just being dave east you know i
mean to where that [ __ ] being something
else i want to build an empire
have you been dabbling in like um
getting involved in other like
avenues of like like other streams of
revenue coming in outside of music yeah
i mean i've been heavy on the uh
designer tip i just i just dropped a
pair of glasses
did a collab with a company called new
vintage um
i got the the clothing line on the way
besides from the merch i'm doing for the
commentary so i got my own line coming
um i'm about to drop a a a cognac based
um like a liquor yeah like a but not but
it's gonna be like a um
like almost like a soda almost like not
something that you ain't gonna be taking
shots of it like you could sit so it's
like a pre-mixed drink
like a yeah but it's gonna be a cognac
base so when you pull up to the liquor
store it'll be already be in the fridge
you just crack it open okay so i just
been trying to you know
use uh my brand
and what i didn't got my name to to just
jump into other avenues you know i'm
saying other avenues i can make money
off of
and um you know just build that future
for my daughter you know i mean for my
team
without me rapping like the rap won't do
what it do you know what i'm saying i
didn't the rap got me into acting
i mean sort of the rapper had shown me
what it could do but now i want to see
what
me being a more of an entrepreneur could
do
acting wise obviously the hulu [ __ ] was
fire but what else i know you uh watch
the whole [ __ ] yeah me and my i finally
got my wife to watch it
when she i told her with some wu tang
[ __ ] and i tried to get her to watch you
know the wu tang documentary that came
out on showtime showtime yeah my wife
don't give a [ __ ] about wu-tang clan
right so i put it on
and it's a documentary this was like
what you know and she just left the room
she's like you could watch that's what
the actual
i'm gonna go upstairs right she don't
give a [ __ ] about woote
but i put the show on and i didn't tell
her it was about wu-tang right
until about 30 minutes in right and she
was like oh this is good
it's just a tv show so yeah i like how
they set that up though they make you
you know i mean you got to watch it
it's really and even like i didn't even
know like a lot of the stuff like
like like and then also just had i had
to figure out everyone else
i was like because because they're not
this like the actual like everyone's
names are different in the show
i was like wait who the [ __ ] is this guy
i knew i knew you were a method man
obviously
but yeah it was it was it was good man
but are there other acting roles or have
you have any other things coming out
because i know that
i'm sure that the entertainment game in
general is on hold
yeah we've supposed to been doing season
two already you know i mean but
the pandemic you guys are supposed to
already start shooting huh yeah
damn i believe they were telling me
y'all gonna have to start doing these
acting bubbles like
you know what i mean like because when
you think about there's so many people
on a set
so many people catering there's so many
people on the set so i i don't see it
don't i can't in the future even see
when
that's going to be free to do again like
you know what i mean even shows
anything on tv you watch movies show all
that [ __ ] no i just mean concerts like
all right
you gotta do that for you from live
shout out to all the southern rappers
who don't give a [ __ ] right now
because they're still running around
getting bags in the south shows down
there some of these cities in the south
do not
care get your money put your mash on go
get your rod wave out here
getting it right now i'm like bro what
random city in georgia is he doing a
whole lot
go get your money did you see boozy
hosting the pool party
i even see that oh my god but you know
what it is i feel like
you know it's um there's as many cases
that that have been proven
is is a hundred percent believable
what's what's going on
i had it just so you know what yeah i
had it me and my wife got it
well you know why because i was a stupid
ass i went back to scottsdale and dj
yeah i i just couldn't smell her taste
damn it doesn't
like words no i like like legit i
thought i was tripping
and you know my my dog's got a little
puppy pad and he took a [ __ ] and i was
like yo
fam i'ma smell i'm gonna get down on the
floor take a whiff of this dog [ __ ] and
see if i didn't smell nothing
did you [ __ ] with your breathing at all
no um towards the end when i was
starting to kick it there was like a 48
hour period where i just was fatigued
and i got through that and then i you
know my smell was coming back and then
i went and got double you know i got two
negative test results in a row and
yeah but yeah no i couldn't i mean i
also asked for i literally went
into a club full of people in scottsdale
scottsdale for a while arizona did not
give a [ __ ] either
we win the club see that's what they can
do york like
like no ain't no clubs like all that
stuff all that's right
so the thing is and now everybody's on
the block again it's
block parties cookouts you know what i
mean so it's a new [ __ ]
people getting the airbnb just throwing
pool parties
do you feel like you get into the
conspiracy aspect of like [ __ ] like
not even just covered but just in
general do you like are you like i think
it's something else
behind us i don't think this is like i
feel like this is all like there's
something else going on
like what though i have no idea we never
know what's like
they always do some [ __ ] then some other
[ __ ] happen like oh you know what i mean
because if you think about it this is my
opinion when all the protesting was
going on
god bless the dead george floyd when all
that happened and everybody was
protesting nobody
you didn't see that nothing about cloven
i never heard the word coveted
no yeah 100 for at least a month
straight i've never even heard the word
and there's people
groups of people everywhere protesting
police was
packed 100 cops everywhere like so then
you know that dies
that died down and then and then they
saying all these cities cases that went
up
you know what i mean they're still
protesting it's just not on the news
yeah the the the
the hype around it and die down unless
it's some wild violent crazy [ __ ] like
portland that's on the news because in
portland this [ __ ] is crazy going down
like anywhere it's going down there's no
going to show you that
in seattle like seattle they had that
little area did you like in seattle they
had like a little
the protesters my little brother live
out there i don't know
yeah there was this [ __ ] called the chat
zone and they shut it off from police
like a whole area of capitol hill
and it was like you couldn't go in and
out unless
it was wild it's going down they said
they you know that that
flame has been set so it's hard but
if it ain't going if it ain't like
something they don't want you to feel
like they need this show they ain't
gonna show you
well they should they just admitted the
pentagon just admitted that ufos are
real
it was in washington time this week yeah
i knew i didn't see an alien or two in
my [ __ ] life
i mean obviously outside of custies you
know what i'm saying
i know how to say that there's some [ __ ]
like from men in black remember that
[ __ ]
oh yeah alien [ __ ] yeah they
admitted to aliens and all that [ __ ]
have you ever uh they probably know him
i know you you the last time we talked
to you probably call them and all that
oh yeah yeah i think they got aliens at
work
i wouldn't put that past none of that
government [ __ ] no they got aliens at
work bro i'm telling you they got
[ __ ] that work for the
government
area what do you think area 51 is these
[ __ ] live on base bruh
crazy it's i'm telling you yo we gonna
see that they're just preparing us
slowly
i think if trump loses before he loses
he's just gonna
[ __ ] everyone's life up and be like
guess what
aliens are real i'm out gonna tell him
to pop out all right y'all can pull up
now
yeah pull up [ __ ] this [ __ ] i lost pull
up i lost
there's gonna be a bunch of aliens
coming through this [ __ ] uh
dave i'm curious i know the last time we
talked we were talking about it was
either you're
the lean [ __ ] or or you had a about with
pills where you said your
your thing wasn't working up to speed it
went viral
oh the uh nazan [ __ ] yeah yeah that's it
i'm curious drug wise uh
have you ever tried any hallucinogenics
like any mushrooms
or dmt you've done shrooms
like how was like you did it twice what
were your what were your experiences
like
uh i had i had two good trips i never
had a bad trip
so both of them was cool but it was like
um
i felt the first time i did it i felt
too high
and i couldn't go to sleep i was trying
to like you know you try to sleep some
[ __ ] off i couldn't go to sleep
usually when you eat stuff you can't
sleep it off i couldn't sleep bro
so that had me that was the only part of
the [ __ ] had me panicking i'm like y'all
can't go to sleep
but i was cool and then the second time
i did it i was
like did you see some [ __ ] like i feel
like some people like they say with you
just colors
that's the that's the only thing like a
lot of people have they say different
all the walls was smelly i didn't see
all that [ __ ] that might
that might have bugged me out but the
colors like all the like
like in this room if i did that [ __ ] in
here all these colors would have
like did something they would they like
glare more like that's all that [ __ ] did
to me but i was like i didn't see no
elephants or
when no midgets running out the room you
got to go out to joshua tree and you got
to do dmt
man [ __ ] his dmt it's that [ __ ]
see peer pressure man you hear about a
brand some brand new [ __ ]
it only lasts like 20 20 15 minutes what
is it it's
it's uh that's some jim that's some
jimmy hendrix it's it's the diameter
what is it
yeah yeah in your brain when you are
born and when you die
this chemical gets released dmt right
and there's a toad that sweats it
naturally
so [ __ ] will take and you you
it's really some crackhead [ __ ] low-key
right so you freebase i ain't never
really like to get into crackhead
no no but it's like you're not smoking
crack but you are freebasing dmt for
sure
off a toad off of a toad's yeah you put
it on like yeah it's it's it's it's wild
but like it's like 15 minutes of like
you just leave the you leave earth for
15 minutes and then 15 minutes later you
come back and and your life might be
changed hey we gotta get some dmt bro
let's do hey look i'm down next time
you're in l.a
we'll get aj turnt up over there but
listen what's the long-term effects of
that nothing there's nothing that read
into that
nothing mike tyson's whole life has
changed because of dmt you know how mike
tyson's like
you know back on his [ __ ] there's a dmt
he smokes the toad man
who you think gonna win with him and roy
jones i don't know
honestly i'm not i i'll say this i
haven't paid a lot of attention to what
roy jones has got going
on but mike tyson looked like i got
tyson no no disrespect to roy i got
tyson knocking him the [ __ ] out
me too bro ike me did you see tyson
knocking him the [ __ ] out the [ __ ] out
the [ __ ] out
like the [ __ ] out because if you think
about it
even if you were to take them both at
their peaks tyson is a heavyweight bro
tyson is still on he's a heavyweight
like roy jones was never i mean i think
he i think towards the end of his career
he dabbled in the heavyweight division
roy nice though no he's nice i always
loved his style when i was a kid because
he was tyson
and then you just see the way tyson has
been looking bro
i don't know bro i think tyson is going
to
take that dude in the world
who you got nate robinson or jake paul
that's the undercard the youtube kid or
nate robinson who used to play for the
bulls and the knicks
they fighting yes so nate robinson do
you remember nate robinson
won the dunk contest so he's fighting
the youtuber jake paul
i'm not familiar with the youtuber he's
just a little white dude he's a little
uh and they and they boxing they bought
some boxes and he's boxing them yeah
and that's the under card or the tyson
and roy jones fight yeah it's crazy
world we're living in right
i'm gonna go with nate raw i don't know
about this youtuber you gotta go in
there
when they rob they robinson looks like
like a miniature 50 cent i'm gonna go
with nate
nate robert i think he we was like five
foot eight or some [ __ ] winning dunk
contest
shout out to nate robinson are you um
are you still [ __ ] with the knicks at
this point in life i don't know what's
going on with them
i respect that man it must be nice to
not know what's going on with sports i
don't know what's going on with that i
wish my bank account wishes that
i didn't know what was going on with
sports for sure
yeah everybody got advice though yeah
i don't i'll say this i'm not alcoholic
i'm not a drug addict
i do enjoy gambling though i like weed
we eat a solid good good weed california
weed
do you think there's such thing as
because you know how like people say you
can't [ __ ] up pizza
is bad weed even good weed just because
it's weed
that was that was like a dr seuss
question say that ask me that
so is bad weed is bad weed good
anyway just because it's just weed or is
there bad is it is bad we just like
oh no there's horrible weed that's like
no point in even smoking
like why would you bring this to me like
it's weed like that's but will it get
you high no so the horrible weed won't
okay no not if you've been smoking great
weed
like it ain't gonna do nothing for you
at all because i know something makes
you mad
so there's we that's crazy you throw me
seed sticks or i should just
just go when's the last time let me ask
you something
you're obviously in different cities all
the time and it's hard to like
you pull up to a random city oh i bring
my weed with me you breathe the weed
unless i come to l.a
the only place in the world where i
won't bring weed
anywhere else i go i'm bringing weed
because it's not gonna be guaranteed
i run into some good weed what is the
best way to fly with
weed outside yeah i know whiz used to
stuff it in like deodorant sticks
like you would just gut the deodorant
i mean you just totally like i mean no i
just pack it
you know the the regulation has changed
flying out of lax well out of lax i'm
talking about let's say you're going to
birmingham alabama
uh they'll be on you like time it's
about how you moving too like
you don't you you do it in the carry-on
or the ch or the second yeah you got to
check it right don't walk through i
of course [ __ ] dogs everywhere but
you know what i learned them dogs is not
sniffing for weeds no they're not they
don't care
they're sniffing for bombs [ __ ]
nerves
yo that dog does not give a [ __ ] if you
got weed that dog gives a [ __ ] if you
got a c4
on the way to the airport i got a whole
[ __ ] half a
[ __ ] pound of bud in the bag and they
got this big ass dog
right here he just cares if you've got a
bomb that's all he cares about he even
paid me no mind i said i'm good
damn um what is the timeline for you and
j stone [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] whenever that shit's done
because karma 3's um
coming out august 14th 14th and then i
got
i got karma 3 fourteen me and styles p
doing beloved two whoo we about to do
that again
bring it bring that back around that was
that was too fun stout speed had a very
underrated 2019
that's you know he put out a lot of
quality hip-hop last year that
that's my guy right there that's big bro
um
so that's so august 14th beloved two and
then a j stone project
yeah and i'm doing one with mary mary
jake doing the album a whole mary j
blige album yo wow we got like maybe
three or four records right now
what talk about that chemistry because
mary's a legend so i mean obviously
i mean just to do one song with her
would be amazing insane but now that's
you know that's one of them like you
such a fan of somebody or you just grew
up on somebody's music or you've been
just you know
tuned into them so long um
it's fire like you know what i'm saying
like it just put me in another zone
knowing who i'm working with
knowing the legacy she already got and
the fact that she even
got to bring bring out that uh that
reasonable doubt
oh the one on the one okay bad boy mary
when you hear that you're going she's
name [ __ ] that's
she on marry on some [ __ ] uh you were
just shooting a video in la
and uh what i thought was amazing i just
scrolling on instagram is a picture of
you and j coles
and i was like oh cole yeah that was
fire shouts to j cole it was that the
first time you guys met
in my life he like my respect level for
him
without the already like you know from
afar saluted
everything he'd do big fan of his music
but um i was shooting a video
uh on sunset he was driving by randomly
and saw me and pulled over
hopped out and i'm saying i was gangsta
a lot of people i know would have been
just like oh what up boy like you know
what i'm saying they kept it pushing
he he hopped out we exchanged numbers
you know what i'm saying i was a combo
man he just like i thought he would have
been man cool i'm saying i just told him
i've been wanting to get with you big
fan of your work
he said boomerang well he stopped too
because he saw you so he must be a fan
of your one that was dope
like i said i never met him before we
never dm'd
we never that was one hip-hop connection
i didn't have you know
yeah i have you ever um
previously tried to reach out to cole or
anything because i feel like musically
you guys would mesh so well
um nah not not not personally or direct
um i was working with wyclef maybe
four year three or four years ago and i
know clef knew him
and i mean we spoke about it right never
never put it together
but honestly with me i like when [ __ ]
like that happened
rather than somebody connecting it right
right right just letting that be
handing that [ __ ] i'd rather just meet
you or we just be at the same place same
time
and then naturally you know i mean that
was dope yeah that's fire uh
and then well dmx was there too soon as
j cole pulled off dmx
hopped out i said damn this is the hell
of a
same corner i'm like no this is the
corner of the bill this is the corner
shout out to dmx man dmx got that dad
bod popping right now
it's the x how did how was that the i
mean i'm assuming have you linked with
actually
x locked locked in uh um i met actually
met
x with swiss swiss beats back in new
york
but um yeah i've been around x a few
times x man cool
i saw dmx's i think he's working on an
album right now you watched the verses
whatever snoop yeah i did it was dope
yeah man they shouldn't have put x
against snoop dogg
now you know that was good for the
culture though it was it was i think
some of those battles it's like
it doesn't matter who wins right like
rizzo versus primo it didn't matter who
won it didn't matter
it was like yo it's rizza vs primo like
you just want to watch just
enjoy it like who gives a [ __ ] who wins
watch it
yeah they're talking like i think the
next oh the rick ross 2 chainz one just
got locked in
which would be crazy yeah swiss chains
got some records
i think i think a lot of people will say
ross but i think you guys
i just when you just said that i thought
about it change got some right you know
of course rose got no i've already
thought about it
i've already thought in my head when he
was titty boy who could beat two
champions he changed his name he had
joints
think about all the features though nice
feature game is
a feature run was crazy crazy yeah
that'll be wild like
i might add that he might have the
meanest feature run right now ever in
hip hop history it's either him or wayne
wayne had that run too like oh he was
going crazy but i think it's chains
james was on everything everything
bodied mercy
you know what i'm saying that's gonna be
a good one
i uh i saw you saw juicy j challenger
man nas to a versus battle
juicy j and nas no i mean it's not going
to happen because that'd be ridiculous
i don't see it no i don't see it either
that's a wild thing to do if you're
juicy j to challenge
nas come on bro but who do you i mean
obviously besides jay-z like uh who who
if you if you had you know you you have
a close relationship with nas like who
do you think would be a
a dope opponent to see to battle him
let's go dan that's tough
i almost feel like
it would have to be him in hole i would
have to say it i'd almost have to be him
and hove
or somebody like it would have to be him
yeah or someone like snooper dmx one of
those like yeah
like like a a nas and a snoop drink
would have been dope
that would have been dope uh i'm trying
to think who else
yeah i would say hello bro it would have
that would be that would be the most
that would make the most sense to me for
them to do because that's who's that
always been that rivalry hey let me ask
you this dave
you're a stellar mc you're one of the
jedi's
what uh song did you get back from
somebody who sent you a feature
that made you either a want to change
your verse change your verse or be like
you know what i'm just gonna have to
hold the l
on this song if ever uh
uh
forbes list okay the first record i deal
with nah yep that was a crazy record
i wanted to change my verse but i just
said you know what i'm a rock
cause you know what it is with me i like
respect
the the the sport you know what i mean
so like
if that's the verse you laid that's the
verse you laid like you know what i'm
saying unless we if we do it together we
do it together but i have
i did that verse prior to him recording
it and then he sent that back and i was
like oh man did you know that nasa was
going to get on it when
i told me no when i laid my part no no
no that's what i'm saying if you would
if you would have known that then i
probably would have did a whole another
verse but that was just you know
that was what he picked and then he was
like what's up with that i'm playing him
wreckage he said what's up with that one
i'm like all right but and he burnt that
[ __ ] he went crazy i'm like oh man
but i'm like you know what it's nice
like you know what i'm saying
let me ask you something there's a what
i'm gonna do there's a big uh i feel
like um
there's a big community of people who
think it was written as nasa's best
album that i've been seeing come to the
forefront lately
i'm a nomadic guy what in your opinion
is naza's best album
it was written it was written okay to me
that that's more my my time you know
matic
affirmative action is one of my favorite
noise records ever yeah crazy
like a z kicked that [ __ ] off something
crazy just that whole beast selection on
that see they talk about b
selection the message was written no no
you talking about beat selection i think
the beat selection
i just think the beat selection portion
of naza's career started like after
later later because you listen to god
son and the beats are [ __ ] crazy
but like hip-hop is dead there was a few
that you were like okay well like
you know what you know yeah but i would
say it was written
i do think who do you think's got the
best year for beats if we're talking nas
i think ross my opinion ross got one of
the hardest here for beats
rick ross got a good ear for beats uh
ken's got a good ear for beats yeah jada
definitely got a good beast um
i'm trying to think who else
i feel like wheezy always had a good
year for beach too yeah wayne for sure
have you ever considered um something
that i think that's been dope
lately is um
artists doing full projects with
producers right so like
freddy did mad lib [ __ ] then he did the
alchemist project conway did a whole
project with alchemist
um i think it'd be super dope to just
hear you do it just lock in with
with one producer cohesive album
is that something you've ever considered
you know it's crazy with that i got like
maybe three of those in the works right
now like i just ain't
like all the way like got in that bag
just because of the other music i'm
working on
but um shouts to mike and keys we're
doing the project just they producing
the whole thing
they actually did um handsome and
minutes of comment three
um i linked up with them through that
yep um
a rap music we got maybe seven records
i mean it's just straight a-wrap you
know what i mean and um
buddha and grants that's my home team
they did
been working doing all my [ __ ] for years
so i was gonna say i would like
maybe three different tapes i i think yo
you gotta like
i would just love to hear you lock in
just with like
just nothing but just you know razor
blades on ikea [ __ ] plates and beats
ikea or like maybe like no who ain't got
where yet that i'm dying to get out
i was going to say i was going to say an
alchemist project he said
but i've been dying like even i've been
in tune with them tape like i love
them tapes action bronson was doing with
him oh my god you know what i'm saying
like all them tapes was
just the way he put a project together
action was really good at working with
whole producers because like he would do
some [ __ ] with party supplies or
yeah i'm producing and then like yeah
but you know what it is with me i feel
like
that would that would make an ill sound
just because i've always
had three beats from this producer two
beats from this producer one from this
but like it's always been a mixture
you know i mean so that's definitely
something i'm gonna do that's something
i'm working on now but that's coming up
do you have a relationship with
alchemist yeah yeah my god
that'll be big man i'll cause my god
have you and primo ever work together
yup
primo's on the end show of survival oh
that's right that's right yeah
we talked about that yeah yeah but he
didn't do the beat right he just did the
scratching he did the scratching but we
got some we got
me primo i think our two rackets because
i i went to his studio to
actually do a record for survival um
and we laid that but then once i got the
record and the rest of the songs for the
album
it didn't mesh but um yeah pretty much
that's the big bro
oh yeah when when you like uh when it's
a primo b do you feel the same type of
expectations as like as
as as if you know it's like you're
getting on a record with nas
exactly same like that's what i feel
like
made me push my pen earlier in my career
i mean like once i got people knew about
me like i was working with certain
people i was like oh i got the rap i got
to
you know i'm saying i got to come with
it each time i'm being heard i got to
come with it
so um definitely with certain producers
like i grew up to all of that
this is all people that i was reading in
the source magazine
you know what i'm saying so now when
they fans at me and i mean and they let
me know that what i'm doing is dope
i got to try to like exceed that
expectation like even more
i mean i was i just saw something online
they were talking about how most rappers
don't
write down anything anymore right and
that
i think it was uh it might have been on
uh
on everyday struggle wayno was talking
like how like those books
like a lot of people's rhyme books one
day are gonna be auctioned
you know what i'm saying do you keep
your rhyme books together do you even
write anymore like what's your process
when it comes to like
writing i personally haven't wrote
nothing down
since beloved
so when you're recording do you um do
you
punch in or you already got the verse
like like do you go line by line
sometimes i punch like line by line or
sometimes i
have the the rhyme i have that [ __ ] in
my head you know i mean and then i'll
even if i got the whole rhyme i might do
like eight
let me hear that then do the next eight
like you know what i'm saying but
my the the writing down i stopped
writing working with stats with me and
staff did
beloved that made me put my pen up i
stopped
i mean i mean i'll still jot [ __ ] down
on my phone certain little clever little
lines and balls
so i can remember well i say it in my
voice don't save it
was that because styles was like that or
you don't write anything you don't write
nothing
so i'm sitting there watching that i'm
in the boo i'm in the in the little
area with my man days with engineer
poops
i'm writing [ __ ] he just walking around
he cut all the lights over he's smoking
he's walking around
beat knocking he going to move switch
12th street
wait wait where's that coming oh so i
gotta now i gotta
challenge my son that but that made me
just get sharper you know what i'm
saying
he was a and me listening to my own
music
you know even if you don't feel like you
reading it you're reading it
when you write you know what i'm saying
if you don't if you if you don't
remember that
even if you write it down you should
still memorize it before you go record
it because if you holding it here you
you still reading it
you know i mean regardless how you feel
so um
i just got more emotion in my music
doing it the other way not reading it
like doing it from my mind cause when i
look like say i go do a freestyle on
flex or whatever
i ain't reading off my phone true that
[ __ ] i didn't memorize
and i didn't you know what i'm saying so
there's more emotion behind it it's more
i know what i'm saying like
i'm not trying to figure out what i'm
about to say like you know i mean i know
what i'm already know what i'm coming
with so it's just strong and then when i
was listening to jay and all these dudes
that they said never wrote you could
hear it
it sounded like they wasn't right you
could tell the difference as an mc i'm
sure when you hear [ __ ] yeah
eminem rights you could tell you know
what i mean like and i ain't never been
around i mean but you could just
you know what i'm saying it's too you
know what i mean
you're not rapping nobody's remember
like it's that's too hard bro that's
still bad for like the generation of
children right now who only know eminem
for like his last three or four albums
because them his new album is dope i'm
not even gonna front the music to be
murdered by [ __ ] was
fire but emma's insane the last few
prior to that were the history of
for for for the future forever like i'm
saying he never wraps it get do another
song
well i'm curious if we're we're taking
out
accolades if we're taking out record
sales lyrically who do you think is the
best ever because i got a few guys that
i'm like i think black thoughts in that
convo
royce is in that convo get busy busy
eminem's in that combo obviously but
like who who do you got up at i mean nas
of course
esko there's guys like sean
price god rest his soul was like one of
them dudes you know what i'm saying who
didn't have the record sales but like by
god talk that talk
uh for show big l
that was l was different with the um
how old are you 31. so we're almost the
same age so
i remember as a kid
i lifestyles of the poor and dangerous i
didn't hear until after the big picture
dropped so i went to the warehouse i
bought the big picture
and then there was that napster wave
remember when napster was talking but i
remember and all that
yeah cause i you would go online and you
download all these freestyles
and i remember the first time i heard
the jay-z big l freestyle
it was like seven minutes and big l
washed hoe
what was that stretching stretch yeah
stretching barbito
that was like but yeah like big l man
[ __ ] big i was so
fired and it was like then though like a
lot of people you see flo got they got
ella later on that back then he was
talking like that like
saying something insane [ __ ] rush in
peace oh that was different
yeah i would say andre 3000.
oh wheezy uh there's a few
lyrics just like that could rap rap rap
pusher i put pushers up here
freddie gibbs is up there that's had a
crazy career fred the guard son
read the gossip recipes yeah and i mean
like it's a few
it's a few yeah shout out to big l man i
do feel like we
our generation always brings big ella
but i don't feel like like kids really
damn i put kim in that i put kim in that
like i feel like kim was one of the
illest with the
the like uh like
like make like he was like he had to
wave like you know what i'm saying like
he could he he could let you know he
could outrap everybody and then he could
play he'd do some pictures i would enjoy
i just see him
i feel like he had phone with him him
and juelz had some of the most
unconventional rhyme schemes where they
would ride the same [ __ ] like six lines
in a row but it'd still be fire
it was totally it was that was i feel
like they uh they just created a
uh era oh for sure what i'm saying they
created a free joelle santana
yeah free jewels they created it who uh
i think
there's three of those errors out of new
york at least from our
life right because wu tang was popping
but we were like kids
like real small kids yeah but we're
talking d
block dip set g unit those three
movements were [ __ ] that's my
that's my life that's me
which which was your favorite out of
those three
uh styles p personal relationship aside
yeah um i mean i said like this they
they all was my favorite at different
times
so i had my time of g-unit like when 50
was dropping the mixtapes
i was locked into that [ __ ] crazy you
know what i'm saying
styles was always my favorite rapper
even during all that time so i was
always listening to d block and then
dip [ __ ] was you know what i'm saying i
actually was around them seeing them
like
yeah differently all three of them at
different times but i was
i mean i didn't i probably never would
like pick and i mean i i could say i'm
personally
now closest with dipset and
in in the locks and i mean i heard that
lloyd banks is um working on coming back
yeah i had banks on what what was the
project what project i have banks on
what table was that a
p2 yeah yeah pizza i think so thanks my
god
he retired and now and i i'm here he's
another one that we
yeah we're talking about back to that
list of them yeah
that bang's workout that victory banks
on that
bro there was this like best of lloyd
banks
volume 2 mixtape that i used to sell
with the swami that was just like
non-stop like
you got to put banks on that list all of
them all of them um the g
freestyles he was going crazy no 100 i
do feel like it's dope too to see like
zelda's like i feel like as far as a
movement out of new york
but it kind of just gives me that that
nostalgia
i feel like that's what really make like
they all individually super fire
but but they they they reminiscent of
that
those times of a group or a crew
and each one of them is different and
they all got a different swag a
different stab but they are crew you
know what i'm saying like
i came out dolo yeah davis you know what
i'm saying like
but when that that crew essence is fire
like you know what i'm saying like that
that's why i really like be sitting back
watching them like because they all
individually can spit but when they move
together it's like you know what i'm
saying look it look it looked dope it
remind you of that that dip [ __ ]
that g-unit that d-block like you know
what i mean to remind you of that and
each of them are
you know like west side gun you're gonna
get that fly [ __ ]
they all got a different but that's what
make it dope none of them is none of
them i like
you know what i'm saying with dip said
none of them wasn't like that's how you
know it was different
none of that wasn't like you know what
i'm saying yo cheryl um i feel like we
got to give styles p has flowers while
he's still here
um because he's one of the all-time
greats give us like a cool stylus piece
story you got man that that
nobody knows about that you haven't
talked about with pete um
i got a bunch of stories with pete i can
honestly say this um
my best friend passed this year um king
shooter
uh my local video out now by the way
yeah that's so um
but p is the only rapper i mean a lot of
people reached out and
you know sent their condolences but pete
um he called me he said yo pull up to
the juice bar
and i mean come i'm gonna come let me
give you a hug you know what i'm saying
like
so that just showed me he's you know i
mean we i just my vibe for him is just
different you know i mean because it's
beyond the rap
he really that's really big bro you know
i mean but he was one of the only ones
that did that
i mean i got a lot of friends in the in
the hip-hop industry you know what i
mean
or or or even us uh i think with with
like will you use that word friends in
the hip-hop industry
i feel like a lot of the relationships
artists have with each other it's it's
they're very like finicky like it's
almost like
you know how it is you run into an
artist somewhere yeah
yeah let's link up a lot of people you
cool for the moment i could count on
maybe one hand people that since i came
in
but i signed when i was 2014 that we've
built the relationship and that's my guy
to this day how's your friendship with
naz in 2020
i'm insane solid solid same
same yeah i feel like
nas is one of those guys who we like
we don't know as much about naz as we
know about all these other legends
because he
cause he's so low-key it's like his
character in belly is like low-key like
he said searing belly is kind of like
the way nas was in real life like
the more low-key guy you know buns was
wild
but you know what i feel like you learn
in this industry man when you've been in
this as long as nas
you know what i'm saying you didn't had
your little mistake shouldn't have to
slip you understand
anything ain't for the public everything
ain't for the world to see you know what
i mean you want that peace of mind that
privacy
and that's that's some [ __ ] i'll be
scoop like it's getting from him like
that's why a lot of you don't see me in
every headline every this one i didn't
have my little troubles in there but
for the most of the part i'll be out the
way do you have you ever um
we were talking earlier about how the
last like
three four five years it's been about
the clout [ __ ]
right and i think like a perfect example
of that is like what's going on with 69
right now it's like a spectacle more
than it's about
his music but do you have you ever felt
any pressure
leave him out of this interview no no
i'm not i'm not i'm not asking you about
him i'm just saying like
like um have you ever felt any pressure
to
like do more [ __ ] on instagram
or or like just based on because i feel
like the entertainment industry
has been in such a weird space
specifically hip-hop because we've been
seeing people who
are just instagram guys getting record
deals like actual
instagram dudes getting signed because
they have followers and [ __ ]
and it hasn't worked out for anybody yet
for the record
i got a lot of people that ain't on
instagram you know i'm saying like a lot
of my
people that i know or that i grew up
with or i'd be around they ain't got
instagram pages like so
they're the ones that that salute me and
you know what i'm saying when they see
me outside somewhere like keep doing
what you're doing homie like
and i'm saying you move we like how you
move like you know what i'm saying so
i can't be one way like that but then be
goofy on the internet you know what i'm
saying i'm just doing [ __ ] to do it like
and i feel like everything you put on
the internet is is is public record and
it's there forever
he's going to be there so my daughter
grow up and see oh dad he was a goof
you was doing something stupid ain't
gonna be none of that and i'm saying
there's a lot of [ __ ] you can't help
you get caught up in there but as far as
the things that's in my control
i'm never gonna goof off right now
that's fair uh karma three is coming out
august 14th 14th
we're here a whole project with mary j
blige is on the way
yeah that's gonna be that's different j
stone project on the way stone project
going away beloved too
what are you cooking man that's what the
quarantine did for me
listen dave you move like a you move
like an independent artist with the
amount of [ __ ] you're putting out
hey man i like the work if if there's
one thing anybody
seen about me since the day you heard
the name davies
i've been working you know i'm saying it
ain't never been no
where you at anytime is a is it's a uh
it's a
it's something not coming out from me it
ain't got nothing to do with me
you know what i'm saying like it's
higher power it's not because of you it
ain't causing me
if it's up to me i'm going to drop i'm
going to get you music i'm going to give
you visuals
i'm going to give you everything i can
give you i'm saying tomorrow ain't
promise
so i got to go that's how i i i i sit
and watch pop
documentaries and nip all these people
that that passed on
and they was working like they knew they
was gonna go you know i'm saying i'm not
thinking in my mind i'm gonna go but i'm
i gotta leave [ __ ] here for when i do
leave you know what i'm saying so
in the meantime while i do got by the
all the girls just saying oh he's
handsome and i've got my good health and
i'm at work
i ain't got time to just be nah i made
it i'm dave east i'll drop next year and
uh i got to go
um let me ask you man i don't know if
you had a relationship with pop smoke
but obviously he's from new york that
was my boy
um great we got [ __ ] we didn't put up
great so you got some unreleased music
with smoke i think they leaked one but
i'm curious like his passing was so
tragic man
i just i talked to him the night before
he died you know what i'm saying like
um great kid man um
like seeing that happen obviously you
being so close to nip and having him
pass the way he
passed does that affect you at all
being a public person who obviously
comes from your background and be around
certain
certain environments do you
[Music]
do you like become a little bit more
protective do you like even paranoid
might even be a word like
like like is that something where you
like adjust the way you move
because [ __ ] man like it's you know
what's crazy about that
before and before that happened to him
or my first album i
i dropped on dev jam's caller paranoia
yeah and that's what that was if you go
watch the interviews that's what i was
talking about
the same [ __ ] that that you know
unfortunately happened
to them like but i've been felt like
that you know what i mean it's just
that kind of make like scared me more
like damn you could be that lit you
could be that known
you know what i'm saying like in the
hollywood hills you could be that known
though like with everybody like you know
that's far away from home
that far away from anybody you probably
got any personal beef with but it's all
about how you moving
you know i mean that's one thing i'm
learning about life is like you know
some [ __ ] is just out of your control
but you got to pay attention once you
become a certain figure
to the world you got to pay attention to
every move it's chess
you know what i'm saying like it's not
well i could just you got to really be
oh no i can't move like that let me send
him to go do that
well i gotta meet let me stay here like
because you don't unders like you don't
know your effect on people
most of the time you're seeing people
they want to take pictures you you're
thinking it's love
but you don't know how a person really
feeling about you or what they would do
to you
to get their name that's what jay said
if i shoot you i'm brainless if you
shoot me you're famous
yeah yeah i mean that's a fact like you
know what i mean so
i just um used both i was like i said
but right before that happened with pop
smoke
we was in the studio every day for maybe
six days yeah talk about y'all's
relationship i wasn't really aware that
you guys were like
he was locked in any time i'd be in
quality being he knew i was in the
building coming in
you come in the room you know i mean me
him in trouble do the record
trouble from atlanta um trouble me and
pop did like three four joints
last time we spoke oh it was all-star i
was in chicago i said you coming out
here
he was like now i'm about to go to l.a
whoa all right
all right mcmahon hit you when i get
back to new york that [ __ ] happened but
yeah i mean that kid was a superstar
even when you like just meet him like
what was something
something about about him that you kind
of took with you in the short amount of
time you guys knew each other just had
good energy
like he was he all he he like he really
uh
was one of them people that like the
rumor and i'm saying when he come in the
building like everybody don't got that
and it don't take jewelry it don't take
none of that like some people just got
that aura
whatever i'm saying like pop had that
you know he had a good aura around him
good vibe about him and you could just
tell he was excited
to be escaping poverty escaping the [ __ ]
we
we come from you know what i'm saying he
could tell he was just excited to be
getting up out of that
so uh that that that crushed me you know
i'm saying that hurt
yeah it was rough i was i'm i'm still
more than nip thinking about nip are you
ever damn saying and then that [ __ ]
happened
and then my boy my boy died right in
this this past
may so i've been arrested these last two
three years been nasty
as far as people you know dying but i
just i take each experience
and uh try to move or do something with
it like everything i got from nip
and the time i got to be around him
fortunately um
i try to apply it to my life you know
what i mean there it is man well look
the album is dropping
and hopefully we're gonna just get a lot
a whole lot of music the rest of these
on
believe it or not my low uh my logo not
only i did that was like a trippy record
for my boy
but i just shot on mission featuring
jazzy
shot that yesterday that's going on i'm
gonna drop that the dated
yeah that's like the um it's like the
first big video
you know i mean but mother drinks is
running up right now
i wanna i'm going now i'm gonna go
visual crazy because i'm sitting on a
lot of music
and it's also been hard to do videos
like yeah it's just like
when the world was closed up it was you
really couldn't you know what i'm saying
camera crews wasn't trying to really do
nothing plus [ __ ] look at you
crazy if in march he was out in the
street shooting videos and [ __ ] i
remember casanova had to apologize
because he was outside we outside shout
out to the cast
shout out to cass man yo davis
appreciate you pull it up always bro you
know the vibe
boom my boy perfect